georges marchais devant les jeunes
communistes ne céderons pas aux
contestataires du pape en allemagne le
chancelier schmitt proposent une journée
par semaine sans télévision
michel meyer a interrogé les allemands
ils ont sauvé 15000 personnes en
maintenant les gendarmes de
haute-montagne fête cet anniversaire
tiercé favori à chantilly 4 2 5 - 2 500
enfants dans l'ordre un tout petit
tiercé nous en parlerons tout à l'heure
madame mademoiselle monsieur bonsoir le
grand beau temps que nous connaissions
depuis quelques jours sur la france a
laissé la place depuis le début de
l'après midi
ainsi elle hélas moins clément la météo
nous avait prévenus elle nous annonçait
des nuages et même quelques orages mais
personne n'y croyait pourtant ce soir il
pleut sur plusieurs régions françaises
et l'on peut encore s'attendre à des
orages cet un ciel maussade donc pour
cette fin de week end ce qui n'a pas
empêché plusieurs dizaines de milliers
de jeunes de participer à ivry à la fête
organisée par le mouvement de la
jeunesse communiste des flonflons à la
barbe à papa de la musique mais aussi de
la politique avec un long discours de
monsieur georges marchais après avoir
condamné la politique économique du
gouvernement et s'être élevé contre les
interventions françaises en afrique
secrétaire général du parti communiste
n'a pas annoncé de modification ni dans
la ligne suivie par le parti ni dans son
organisation
cela d'ailleurs aurait surpris
musique chez les jeunes communistes avec
léo ferré informations avec les stands
régionaux et internationaux politiques
avec le discours de georges marchais le
numéro un du pc a condamné beaucoup de
monde le gouvernement pour sa politique
économique et ses interventions au zaïre
et au tchad
les socialistes toujours responsable de
l'échec électoral et avec lesquels il
n'est plus question de se réconcilier
les fractionnaire et autres critiques du
parti qu'ils ne seront pas exclus bien
que condamnée mais auquel georges
marchais ne cédera pas nous ne voulons à
aucun prix de l'instauration dans notre
partie de courant et de tendances qui
ruinerait sa vie démocratique qui le
transformerait qui le transformerait en
champlost de rivalités personnelles et
de querelles de clans qui donnerait à
l'adversaire de classe des moyens rêver
de manipuler des communistes contre doté
de peser sur nos décisions nous ne
voulons en aucun prix d'une politique
qui consisterait à engager notre parti
dans les facilités trompeuses et
finalement meurtrière de la capitulation
devant la social démocratie
nous ne voulons pas plus d'un repli
doctrinaire qui transformerait le parti
en petite secte sans aucune influence
sur la réalité nationale
nous ne voulons à aucun prix qu'un petit
groupe gagné par le vertige et prenant
appui sur l'extérieur s'arrogent le
droit de changer d direction
démocratiquement élu par l'ensemble des
communistes
tout cela nous ne voulons pas parce que
ce serait abandonner la ligne définie
par notre 22e pompe
jean françois kahn ses propos très durs
de monsieur georges marchais prouve une
chose les contestataires du parti
communiste ont échoué finalement dans
leurs tentatives ils ne feront changer
ni la ligne du parti ni la direction ni
les méthodes de gouvernement du parti
communiste et au comptant dans
l'impression qu'aujourd'hui c'est le pc
qui contre attaque
en effet au début ça avait été le
silence vous souvenez on ne parlait pas
des quelques contestataires qui
s'étaient manifestés ensuite j'avais été
un peu le coup du mépris aux rouilles à
30-40 contestataires d'idées georges
marchais maintenant la direction du
parti communiste c'est que par exemple
cette fameuse motion des 300 militants
contestataires a recueilli plus de 1000
signatures donc le problème est pris au
sérieux et c'est vraiment alors un
véritable contre attaque nous venons de
le voir mais alors quelle va être sa
technique employée par le parti
communiste pour mettre au pas les
contestataires
on le voit bien longtemps dans le propos
des javas l'exclusion george marshall
premier stade si vous voulez je crois il
s'agit d'isoler les plus turbulentes à
dire on dit aux autres mais nous
acceptons tout à fait que dans les
cellules dans les sections critiquent la
politique du parti
oui dans le cadre du parti lui-même mais
autre chose et de s'exprimer dans la
presse anti communistes ou le signer le
manifeste donc on les isole cela les
plus turbulents deuxième stade on
utilise tel ou tel propos de l'un ou
l'autre des contestataires pour montrer
qu'en fait il s'agit d'une sorte de
complot si vous voulez qu'ils
s'organisent et qui veut s'en prendre la
direction du parti et troisième stade on
sous-entend que ce qu'on peut plus ou
moins manipulés par les socialistes et
que de toute façon il fait le jeu de la
droite
on est un peu la méthode oui voilà pour
la méthode mais le parti communiste va
quand même devoir convaincre l'ensemble
des militants de
du bien fondé sur l'analyse et la flore
qui joue sur les cordes sensibles de
laquelle va-t-il choisir moi je crois
vous savez lundi le parti communiste
organise
il a pris seul l'initiative d'organiser
une manifestation à paris contre les
interventions françaises en afrique et
je crois que c'est la réponse c'est à
dire il va faire appel au patriotisme de
parti il va dire regardez le parti
communiste se bat contre la politique
africaine du pouvoir regarder ce qui se
passe chez renault ou chez boussac le
parti communiste est en train de se
battre sur le plan social alors ce n'est
pas le moment où nous sommes dans des
luttes politiques dans les luttes
sociales de se quereller de se perdre
dans des querelles internes
il faut resserrer les rangs et soul et
vous à ce propos qu'en 56 il y avait
déjà eu une certaine contestation au
sein du pc à cause des événements de
hongrie
et puis certaines manifestations de
droite avait dégénéré et les
manifestants avaient voulu brûler ces
jeux l'humanité envahir le comité
central les spas et puis il ya eu
l'intervention à suez
alors aussitôt il ya eu appel au
patriotisme du parti on avait resserré
les rangs et effectivement la
contestation avait été en quelque sorte
et critique jean-françois merci
de son côté monsieur françois mitterrand
s'adressait à bordeaux sur le thème de
la décentralisation aux conseillers
généraux socialistes qui étaient réunis
pour une conférence nationale monsieur
mitterrand en a profité pour critiquer
l'information pour lui le gouvernement
se sert du monopole de la radio et de la
télévision pour écraser moyens
d'information la télévision est un
moindre degré la radiodiffusion sont
pour le pouvoir central sous l'alibi de
la démocratie directe
un moyen extraordinaire des fassiez
d'effacer les différences de nier des
diversités de ruiner
et naturel divergences politiques et de
s'adresser au corps indistincte du
peuple français de telle sorte que ce
dialogue faussé par un usage délétère du
monopole ont fondu entre un service
public qui devrait être par définition
le service de tous et qui devient le
monopole des partis politiques de la
majorité pour parler plus clair le
monopole comme il aime ce terme des
forces économiques qui gouverne en
vérité notre pays nous assistons un
processus d'écrasement du citoyen le
reste les paroles ne sont que le boom
qu'on verse sur la plaie pour qu'elle ne
soit pas sensible mais en vérité vos
régions vous assemblées régionales sauf
dans les rares cas où nous disposons
d'un pouvoir politique
sainte foy et peut-on même usé de ce
pouvoir pleinement dans les cinq à que
je connais nos régions la mienne celle
de la plupart d'une petite province ne
sont que des instruments du pouvoir
colette puisque nous sommes dans les
problèmes de la radio et de la
télévision je vous propose y rester
quelques minutes le chancelier helmut
schmidt il ya quelques jours a lancé une
idée qui a beaucoup surpris des
allemands nous regardons trop la
télévision at il écrit dans un article
publié par l'un de nos confrères
d'outre-rhin
résultat on ne se parle plus cela c'est
la constatation mais monsieur helmut
schmidt propose une solution
et si la télévision se taisaient pendant
un jour chaque semaine
l'allemagne fédérale se privant de
télévision une fois par semaine c'est
l'image futuriste que l'on peut imaginer
après la lecture d'un article que vient
de rédiger le chancelier helmut schmidt
le chef du gouvernement allemand rend en
effet le petit écran responsable de
l'appauvrissement des contacts et des
relations humaines au sein de la société
ouest allemande
le chancelier font de cette intuition
sur un constat qu'il buvait inquiétant à
l'heure actuelle en effet 73 % des
allemands regardent la télévision
quotidiennement ils sont 80 les samedis
dimanches
selon helmut schmidt l'allemagne de
l'ouest se transformerait donc en une
masse dermit à cause de 2h10 passer
chaque jour devant les étranges lucarnes
germaine il parle donc de
surconsommation de télévision surtout
puis les enfants si je m'imagine que des
enfants de 10 et 15 ans préfère passer
tout leur temps livre de mon écran au
lieu d'aller jouer dans les rues dans
les squares et cetera c'est quand même
un danger
l'allemand discute - en famille par
exemple en comparaison avec un français
avec un italien
c'est dans son tempérament et évidemment
le père qui rentrent et et qui
s'installe en face de l'appareil télé et
qui a sa bouteille de bière à son côté
évidemment comme ça il n'ya pas tu
communication en famille et il n'y a pas
de contacts humains
en même temps qu'ils s'attaquent à la
violence à la télévision
le chancelier schmitt déplore aussi sur
les antennes le mélange souvent trop
subtil entre fiction et réalité
sa proposition de jeunes télévisuelle
une fois par semaine est dans l'ensemble
plutôt bien accueilli par les allemands
à la condition que ce jour sans
télévision ne soient pas imposées par
décret nous dit-on ici les jeunes
surtout se rendent assez bien content de
l'omniprésence du petit écran dans la
vie familiale
le stress de la vie actuelle à l'école
ou sur les lieux de travail nous mange
littéralement le risque est grand dans
perdre sa personnalité retrouve donc
positif d'aménager des heures sans
télévision afin de se retrouver soi-même
et de se rééquilibrer
à vrai dire et avec un brin de mauvaise
conscience
les allemands se sentent déjà un peu
malade une télévision qui a sauf dans de
très rares foyer partiellement éliminer
les jeux et les discussions helmut
schmidt entend donc inciter à une
réflexion sur ce sujet son initiative ne
manque cependant pas d'arrière pensée
je pense personnellement que le
chancelier a quand même une
arrière-pensée
il y a des plans d'installer 30
programmes de télévision en allemagne
par la télévision par câble et c'est
d'abord l'état le gouvernement à bonn
les gouvernements régionaux qui doivent
payer les expériences qui sont prévues
alors on a bien l'impression que le
chancelier prépare le terrain pour
pouvoir poser la question aux gens vous
voulez vous vraiment 30 programmes à la
maison on en avait déjà trois dans
certaines régions 5 et 6 est-ce que cela
ne suffit pas
seule une semaine politique importante
qui s'ouvre en france sur le plan
parlementaire trois débats sont prévus à
l'assemblée est tout d'abord celui sur
la politique étrangère qui s'ouvrira
jeudi un débat qui sera dominée par les
sujets qui impose l'actualité l'afrique
et le désarmement
monsieur valéry giscard d'estaing lui
quitte paris mercredi pour la corse il
reviendra dans la capitale vendredi
entre temps il aura prononcé quatre
grands discours de ajaccio 1 à corte est
le dernier à bastia
de nombreux policiers ont été envoyés en
renfort en corse ils n'ont pu empêcher
toutefois les plastiqueurs d'agir une
villa appartenant à monsieur jean
riolacci ancien préfet de la corse et
actuellement conseiller auprès du
président de la république à l'elysée a
été totalement détruite cette nuit
l'attentât n'a pas fait de victime
une autre bombe a explosé le jour en
corse elle visait une personnalité
connue elle pour ses opinions
disons autonomistes et puis les députés
rpr de l'accord sont écrit au chef de
l'état ses députés assure monsieur
giscard d'estaing de leur total soutien
mais s'ils reconnaissent que beaucoup a
déjà été fait par les pouvoirs publics
aux yeux de bien des corses
tout reste encore à faire lorsque les
députés entameront jeudi le débat de
politique étrangère les premiers
parachutistes du 2e étranger seront déjà
rentrés sur leur base en corse le pont
aérien mis en place pour le rapatriement
du deuxième raid par les américains
commencera à fonctionner dès mercredi
sur place au zaïre il ne restera plus
que les troupes africaines composée de
marocains et bientôt de congolais et de
sénégal demain à paris cette situation
au coeur de l'afrique sera au centre des
discussions qu'auront les représentants
français américains allemands
britanniques et belges participant au
sommet sur la sécurité en afrique un
sommet qui est très critiquée à moscou
où l'on y voit la naissance d'un nouveau
colonialisme dirigé par washington
pour les cinq qui se rencontrent à paris
comme pour mon goût tout l'objectif est
double d'abord assurer la sécurité du
pays une tâche qui est au dessus des
possibilités actuelles de l'armée
zaïroise elle sera donc seconde et par
un contingent de 15 cents soldats
marocains ils seront transportés à bord
d'avions cargo de l'aviation américaine
dans la province du shaba ces mêmes
appareils assureront l'évacuation des
légionnaires français dont la mission au
zaïre est donc sur le point de se
terminer
de plus une force africaine dont on
ignore encore la composition et
l'importance pourrait rapidement
rejoindre les marocains à lubumbashi et
kolwezi
non
kolo esi à peine sorti du cauchemar a
reçu la visite du président mobutu
il est ainsi rappelé dans la principale
cité minière du shaba que son deuxième
objectif après la sécurité et de relever
l'économiser
à cet égard il est assuré de lattes de
pékin dont le ministre des affaires
étrangères vient d'arriver à kinshasa le
ministre chinois a présenté la récente
invasion du shabak comme une agression
mise au point selon ses propres termes
par les impérialistes de rue l'envoyé de
pékin a été interrogé sur l'éventualité
d'une admis les terres chinoises aux ax
il n'a rien exclu
nous en parlerons at il dit avec les
responsables aéro à la 110 du foyer de
jeunes enfants inadaptés qui a fait
trois morts cette nuit à pontoise non
loin de paris reste ce soir toujours
totalement inexplicable personne ne peut
dire comment le bâtiment a pris feu à
bâtiment qui était agréé et qui avait
été inspecté la dernière fois le 26
avril dernier dans ce centre en quelques
minutes deux enfants et un éducateur
sont morts ce dernier alors qu'il
tentait de se courir ce dont ils avaient
la charge cet enfant ont également été
blessés
les blessure bénigne qui ne
nécessiteront qu'une très courte
hospitalisation
tous les autres occupants de l'immeuble
ont pu être sauvés par les
sapeurs-pompiers en haute montagne des
médecins tentent une expérience
originale l'un des dangers de la
montagne en cas bien sûr de chutes ou
d'accidents
c'est ce que l'on appelle l'hypothermie
c'est à dire le refroidissement du corps
de médecins de l'hôpital de chamonix ont
donc conçu avec l'aide des gendarmes de
haute montagne un appareil destiné à
produire de l'air chaud facilement
transportable qui permettrait de
soutenir de soutenir la température du
corps d'un blessé en attendant bien sûr
les secours un nouveau système donc qui
permettra peut-être de sauver encore
plus de vies humaines
en tout cas depuis 20 ans quinze mille
personnes ont été sauvées en montagne l
ont été par la gendarmerie le peloton de
gendarmerie de haute montagne de
chamonix existe depuis 1958 l'an passé
ces hommes ont effectué plus de deux
mille opérations de secours en haute
montagne pour l'instant c'est encore un
peu la période creuse pour eux mais dans
quelques jours au dessus de chamonix le
téléphérique de l'aiguillé du midi
transportera tous les jours plusieurs
milliers de personnes à 3800 mètres
d'altitude
or là pour les gendarmes lors des
vacances sera terminé
comme ils le font presque tous les jours
depuis vingt ans des hommes d'un peloton
de gendarmerie de haute-montagne partent
pour essayer d'arracher à celles ci des
alpinistes en difficulté
un travail qui a déjà coûté la vie à 18
sauveteurs
la météo est bien sûr épouvantable
à chamonix l'année dernière il y a eu 33
morts un bilan très lourd mais qui
aurait pu être beaucoup plus
une vingtaine d'années c'est le temps
qu'il faut un glacier comme celui des
bossons à chamonix pour rendre ce qu'ils
avaient englouti
voici les restes de l'hélicoptère qui
s'était écrasé lors du sauvetage de
vincent dont et henry en 1957
mais le massif emprisonne encore 500
personnes ensevelies dans cette
immensité glaciers parfois sur la
moraine on retrouve un gant une
chaussure il ya trois semaines encore
dans cette coulée d'avalanche
le pilote de l'hélicoptère a cherché
longtemps des montagnards surpris
on a retrouvé deux et trois voiliers rac
et des parties de l'est par tous ces
partis sont ici emporté par une coulée
dans la traversée entre ces grands
brûlés et le plan technique en 77
la trentaine de gendarmes du peloton de
haute montagne sont intervenus plus de
250 fois depuis 2001 ou dans les cours
hélicoptère est prêt à décoller en
permanence on gagne grâce à lui des
heures précieuses lors des opérations de
sauvetage
par mauvais temps surtout du vent on
gèle très rapidement d'abord comme les
lézards on perd les extrémités pied
humain c'est une défense de notre
organisme mais ensuite c'est la
température du corps tout entier qui
baissent et les lésions sont fatales
heureusement aujourd'hui c'est un
exercice et il fait beau
dans des conditions atroces un peu plus
et palm os après c'était pas tant parce
que à partir du moment où l'on décolle
et qu'on juge que la mission n'avait pas
besoin non plus quand même des
tentatives
bon ben allal al libi halal épices de
toujours décapant
parce que j'avais dépassé ne jamais
dépasser ses limites cela paraît évident
et pourtant sur ce parcours glaciaire de
la vallée blanche utilisé en saison par
deux mille personnes tous les jours
les accidents ne se comptent plus ici
c'est l'un des endroits les plus
dangereux car lescurry pique nique et
quittent leurs skis sans savoir où il
met les pieds très travaillée comme le
dira
devant nous il y a des crevasses dans
laquelle on pourra mettre la lune
cathédrale notre dame de paris par
exemple je suppose c'était du cavité
immense et très profonde
environ 150 mètres
beaucoup d'accidents de montagne qui
sont dus à l'imprudence
la preuve ici on hésite à s'encorder
lorsqu'on des choses c'est ce qui
résulte en quatre ans 148 blessés
les dangers objectifs tels la foudre les
plaques à vent ou les chutes de pierres
sont responsables d'une minorité de
pépins mais ce qu'il fallait méritait il
ya encore quelques années est offert
aujourd'hui même aux néophytes
en quelques minutes le téléphérique nous
transporte en basket à plus de 3800
mètres et ainsi on a tendance à oublier
que la montagne n'est pas un boulevard
une cordée vie qu'une seconde cordée il
ya eu deux morts quatre blessés que nous
avons évacué sur chamonix le couloir du
glacis de la noire une corde et dévisse
de blessés là dans les airs acte la
vallée blanche
trois chutes en crevasse deux blessés
graves une victime la haute montagne et
changeante et même l'été elle ne
pardonne pas à ceux qui la considère
avec mépris
et puis parfois l'hélicoptère ne peut
pas décoller d'habitude lorsque alain
bosquet parmi nous c'est qu'ils viennent
nous parler d'un livre publié par un
pote chaque mois vous pouvez ainsi le
retrouver dans une de nos éditions de 23
heures le jeudi
généralement aujourd'hui nous allons
retrouver mais dans un exercice tout
différent à la mosquée vient en effet de
publier un roman les souvenirs d'enfance
ou le titre une mère russe les rapports
entre une mère et son fils la réalité
d'un amour exclusif pour une seule
personne alors pour vous donner envie de
lire ce livre alain gillot-pétré a voulu
en savoir plus long sur alain bosquet
une mère russe est sans doute le
meilleur roman d'alain bosquet
l'histoire tourmentée de sa mère morte à
paris l'an passé ce livre est à ton body
l'auteur celui d'une mère russe
pourquoi russe une mère est toujours une
mère parce que le tempérament russe
imprévisible adorable insupportable et
assez contraire à mon tempérament
cartésien mois et deuxièmement le fait
est qu'elle est née en russie et qu'elle
y a
et qu une vie heureuse jusqu'à ce
qu'elle a été chassé par la révolution
en 1919 et après eh bien ça a été une
série d'exode la bulgarie et piquent
leur retour chez mes ancêtres belge à
bruxelles où elle a vécu jusqu'à 40
et cette chambre d'hôtel nous sommes fut
la dernière maison de votre mère vous
n'auriez pas pu vivre avec elle non
c'était la dernière maison parce que une
fois son mari mort mon père mort et les
revenus auprès de moi je les reprises en
quelque sorte
et elle a voulu vivre dans un endroit
tout est fait ni tout à fait nul est
tout à fait neutre aussi est bon elle a
réappris à vivre avec moi ce qu'elle
n'avait pas fait depuis près de 40 ans
si vous avez mis votre mère en chapitres
il s'agissait en fait d'une libération
la prison vous appelez l'enfer de la
tendresse
oui tous les vrais maîtres un chapitre
c'est là dessus que les choses sont
importants et que je suis moi tout de
même un écrivain professionnel
alors je me trouve que ce soit ma mère
où vous ou n'importe qui c'est un
personnage non top paire se marre je
fais partie d'un livre si le parti d'un
livre est tout à fait la vie vécue
vous voyez le malentendu voyez la mer en
la marge d'erreur est aussi l'hommage
qu'on peut rendre à quelqu'un qui est
mort le fait que vous m'interrogez
aujourd'hui sauf que moi je les ai un
peu prolongé et vous avez eu besoin
d'écrire ce livre
comment s'exprimer quand on n'a pas
comme vous le bonheur d'écrire je ne
sais pas vous savez je ne m'interroge
pas je me dis que physiquement j'avais
besoin
peu après la mort de ma mère de me dire
qu'est ce que nous avons été l'un pour
l'autre et de faire passer sa part une
chose très simple qui est naturel chez
moi et au jeu et ekema seule valeur
c'est-à-dire de mettre des mots potable
je ne suis rien d'autre qu'un être
quelconque mais qui chez un peu aigri
et vous sentiment que maintenant vous
êtes libre je ne crois pas je crois que
maintenant le mickey l'allégeance se
prolonge et j'ai en moi ce sentiment
égoïste lui avoir rendu quand même
hommage avec ce livre dont votre
question de début son seul tombeau c'est
pas le doute pierre qu'elle a dans un
cimetière près de paris c'est ce bouc
une mère russe de la basket
il a encore gagné strasbourg paris il
sait josy ciment un peu plus de soixante
six heures pour franchir à pied les 501
km qui séparent mutzig de
nogent-sur-marne choisi simon un habitué
de la victoire c'est aujourd'hui c'est
la quatrième pour lui
oui patrick je peux vous dire une faut
dire d'ailleurs que c'était proche série
la plus longue et la plus difficile du
monde 9 survivants seulement à l'arrivée
vers sète la plus terrible tournée des
amis c'est le triomphe d'un homme le
luxembourg où bat 45 ans josy sinon il a
pratiquement fait la course en tête d'un
bout à l'autre et voyez vous je ne sais
pas ce qu'il faut à peine plus les
capacités physiques de ces sommes tous
ces hommes ou leur prodigieuse
résistance morale mais c'est aussi une
question d'organisation chaque marcheur
disposent d'une ou deux équipes de
spider qui se connaît dans un de camping
car ou le programme de l'alimentation
grande partie dicté des règles comme un
horaire de chemin à faire
cela dit c'est quand même un sacré
calvaire et trois autres aux nuits sans
sommeil par deux notions de commun
qu'ils faut le faire bravo donc j'ose
issimo et bravo à tous croyez moi il le
mérite
et oui même au dernier il y avait un
tiens c'est aujourd'hui à chantilly une
grande course puisqu'il s'agissait du
prix du jockey club et pour l'emporter
il fallait jouer le 4 le 2 et le 5 4
c'est à cammas le 2 c'était frère basile
et le 5 tueur ville nous allons envoyer
l'arrivée la de ce tiercé les rapports
avec l'onu les données en commençant ce
journal il ne sont pas préservés
nous allons je pense qu'à découvrir
aussi son handicap ont voulu donner un
truc à 4 185 francs pour 5 francs dans
le bon ordre et 97 francs toujours pour
sa croix mais dans un ordre différent
pas de quoi sabler le changement après
avoir affecté dans la nuit la région
parisienne le massif central et les
pyrénées la zone orageuse que nous
connaissons actuellement sur ces régions
va se déplacer vers l'est l'alsace
toutefois sera épargné ailleurs le temps
demain sera variable en faisant alterner
beaucoup de soleil et las quelques
nuages il faut s'attendre aussi à une
hausse des températures aujourd'hui
c'est d'ailleurs l'est de la france qui
détenait le record pour le thermomètre à
17 heures il faisait encore 27° à nancy
et à strasbourg
voilà cette édition est maintenant
terminée une fois que la carte sera
effacé cette émission est maintenant
terminée aux alentours de 22 heures 40
22h45 vous retrouverez hervé claude pour
le dernier journal de ce dimanche
je vous souhaite bien sûr de passer une
très bonne fin de soirée pour soi